nous accueillons aujourd'hui n'avalera
schalit la directrice générale de
l'institut d'innovation en logistique
que tu québec
bonjour d'abord l'achat les bons jours à
bout à monsieur c'est mieux d'aller en
décembre 2019 vous avez été désigné
comme directrice générale de l'institut
d'innovation en logistique du québec va
commencer par le début en quoi consiste
votre travail à investiguer en fait pour
répondre à votre question je vais
d'abord vous dire c'est comment c'est
venu cette désignation parce que je
travaille à l'institut et depuis depuis
et d'ailleurs c'est juste après mon
immigration que j'ai travaillé la pige
et j'ai commencé par une pensée hier
logistique ensuite chargé de projet pour
être désigné en fait j'ai gardé les
échanges comme comme une grande pour
être une directrice générale de
l'institut puis je suis quand même
reconnus par les la communauté des
experts en logistique et transport comme
une des expertes au niveau du québec en
logistique et donc notre travail à
l'institut d'innovation le cycle du
québec
on a quatre émissions ont fait d'eux les
techniques tu as des entreprises et des
manufacturiers ou des entrepôts qui ont
des problématiques de gestion
d'entreposage de distribution c'est
qu'on les accompagne autant à implanter
des nouveaux systèmes mois à améliorer
leur fonctionnement
ensuite si la technologie ou la solution
n'existe pas c'est que là on peut faire
des recherches appliquées des projets de
recherche appliquée et donc là ça peut
consister à des algorithmes par exemple
d'optimisation des hôtes dans une région
dans pour une filière et en résoudre la
problématique par vraiment des scénarios
de simulation et c'est donc ensuite on
donne aussi des formations en entreprise
c'est à dire pareil ayant des
problématiques de gestion d'entrepôt
envoie en entrepôt qui en fait des
ateliers de travail et d'accompagnement
et 3,3 quatrième volet plus tôt c'est la
sensibilisation à nouvelles technologies
de logistique de transport donc on est
toujours en
et sur les nouvelles technologies qui
sont en europe aux états-unis s'y fait
quand on fait ce transfert d'expertisé
des connaissances autant à des
entreprises mais aussi aux étudiants du
cégep andré laurendeau c'est notre cégep
d'appartenance donc on a des décors de
formation ici avec des étudiants on a
laboratoire de technologie et on essaie
de faire cette affiliation et puis ce
pour qu'il puisse répondre au marché
d'emploi quand ils vont être diplômés
tout un travail j'imagine mais vous même
temps je voudrais revenir sur votre
parcours
cette désignation à la tête de
l'institut d'innovation
elle intervient à pratiquement 10 ans
après votre arrivée au canada
alors pour nous observateur quel est le
secret ou la recette de cette ascension
selon vous dirai tout un chemin pour
être à la direction de l'institut en
fait comme j'ai dit au début j'ai
commencé par le français en logistique
et puis arrivé ici comme j'ai étudié en
france donc c'est pas le même milieu de
travail c'est pas le même la même
mentalité
donc il fallait un peu s'adapter à cette
nouvelle culture d'entreprise et je suis
très reconnaissante là plusieurs
québécois qui m'ont vraiment soutenu que
mon coach et je nomme notamment trois
personnes sur lui qu'un saut qui m'a
donné cette occasion justement pour
travailler à l'institut c'était le
directeur général à l'époque madame luce
la porte qui était la directrice
adjointe puis à ce jour je travaille
encore avec elle et monsieur alain
tremblay ces trois personnes mangent
irait adopté et il m'a permis de ma
croître autant au niveau culturel t
comment l'intégrer à leur a alors comme
je dis culture mais aussi à leur mode de
vie
j'ai découvert qu'on avait des pas des
valeurs en commun mais c'est des choses
qui arrivent au fur et à mesure puis
j'ai même eu des relation plus
personnelle avec ces gens là qui
maintient au sein de leur famille qui
fait que c'est cette intégration moi que
je trouve très très important mais ça
part d'une confiance
entre les deux parties est aussi il nous
met quand même à l'épreuve c'est qu'on
arrive on arrive avec un bagage mais des
fois puis je n'en parlerai plus tard on
est sûr qualifier on a des compétences
fait comment les mettre en valeur
comment les adapter sans trop exagérer
donc être entre les dents le milieu donc
si j'ai eu j'ai eu un petit moment
d'intégration de coaching puis quand ils
ont découvert mes capacités
c'est là que les portes s'ouvrent donc
là ses limites et c'est j'étais en route
10 ans à travers tout le québec à faire
des missions un peu partout chaudière
appalaches en estrie si j'allais aller à
sherbrooke deux trois fois par semaine
pour travailler au centre d'alliés de
cherbourg pour faire des projets j'étais
partout et j'étais tellement tellement
ravie de cette richesse parce que ça m'a
permis autant de de parler le dialecte
de certaines régions des régions qui
n'ont jamais connu des arabes qui ont
jamais vu des arabes que si j'arrivais
l'appui c'était c'était tellement
impressionnant j'ai même été baptisé et
noëlla par une des clientes parce
qu'elle n'arrivait pas dire mon nom ce
que c'est c'est cute
comme on dit la messe et j'ai beaucoup
apprécié donc à travers cette expérience
de cancer en logistique chargé de projet
j'avais des équipes et par la suite
nomination à la direction d'avoir sali
pendant tout ce parcours vous avez vous
aviez à relever certains défis canton
qui migrantes et en tant que femme
immigrante vous nous en parler un peu
tout à fait d'en parler d'immigration
d'intégration ça c'est correct mais pour
s'intégrer il faut avoir de la valeur
ajoutée pour ce pays donc il faut
trouver un emploi c'est ça la difficulté
que moi j'ai rencontré au début c'est
que premièrement je dépose des cv puis
il n'y a pas de pas de réponse je me dis
pense pas grave parce que ma première
année que j'étais ici je terminais au
même pendant mon doctorat donc pour moi
c'était pour connaître le marché
ensuite je passais
entrevue pour certains postes et je
demandais pas des postes à haut niveau
je demandais commune des postes que pour
juste pour m'intégrer parce que
généralement on nous demande une
expérience au canada une expérience
professionnelle et qu'il faut commencer
quelque part c'est même en bas d'échelle
dix ans mais il faut commencer fait que
j'ai postulé pour des dépôts ce qui sent
comme plus bas que mon niveau mais
c'était correct pour moi ya pas de
problème donc quand j'ai passé mon
entrevue je n'étais pas accepter puis je
me disais c'est là où on est un peu
comme confronter à la réalité on dis et
pas ce que je demandais plusieurs fois
mais pourquoi ceux reçus
là c'était vous êtes sûr qualifier mais
pour moi la j'accepte de travailler
pourtant pour ce poste et je suis sûr
qualifier c'est bon pour vous pour moi
dans ma perception à l'époque mais plus
tard j'ai compris une autre chose mais à
l'époque je me disais mais le pays fait
venir justement des compétences des gens
qualifiés mais s'il n'y a pas de marché
d'emploi pour ces gens qualifiés comment
les intégrer comme en profiter niveau
économie ultra c'est vraiment une
richesse en a au pays puis qu'on n'en
profite pas donc et c'est là que je me
suis dit ok ces difficultés il faut les
contourner je vais pas toujours comment
postuler à des offres qui sont sur le
marché
je vais je vais contourner un peu le
système est dans le système c'est à dire
la démarche intelligente essayer d'aller
d'aller voir qui ce qui se fait dans le
marché au niveau des centres de
recherche parce que quand je faisais un
doctorat
je voulais voir mathématiques de
doctorat qu'est ce qui est fait ici
faire un peu de veille un peu de
benchmark voir qu'est ce qu'ils ont
réalisé
et c'est là que j'ai découvert qu'il y
avait des failles que j'ai étudié en
france était tellement avancé par
rapport à ici au québec
quand je suis arrivée dont ils étaient
des dizaines d'années de retard au
niveau technologique fait que je
travaille sur la traçabilité bedouet
fait que les systèmes de traçabilité
[Musique]
à l'époque n'existait pas trop où il y
avait juste des systèmes d'information
mais qui faisait pas de la crasse
habilité il y avait un gros besoin est
là ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai
commencé à frapper les portes puis à les
voir juste les centres de recherche des
entreprises besoins des instituts juste
pour discuter c'était pas pour proposer
mes services ce n'était pas pour
demander un emploi et pour ma
connaissance générale pu voir où est ce
qu'ils sont rendus et c'est là que j'ai
rencontré justement celui carso qui
était l'ancien directeur de l'institut
je veux juste bien parce que j'ai vu
qu'ils avaient un site web sur en route
vers la traçabilité howe s'écrit points
non mon domaine dextérité
je vais aller les voir je viens le voir
puis là il me dit
nawal je te laisse pas partir je fais
comme voyons en quoi c'est il me dit
fais cinq minutes je reviens il est
acquitté je me rappelle tellement
l'impie revient il me dit j'ai une offre
pour toi pour tout de suite mais c'est
pas quelque chose à mon niveau je suis
désolé mais je te promets je te créer un
poste pour toi dont deux mois est ce que
c'est la chance est-ce que ses équipiers
qui demandent au fils mon profil était
était intéressant qu'il y avait un
manque mais le mot n'était pas soulevé
dans le marché si c'est ça c'est pour ça
je dis aux gens ne vous limitez pas aux
offres d'emploi qui sortent parce que là
c'est tout le monde postule et surtout à
montréal
c'est très saturé donc il faut il faut
sortir un peu des sentiers puis puis
chercher à de différentes manières et se
créer un réseau professionnel ça c'est
important ça c'est parmi les défis vous
l'avez pratiquement c'est comme si vous
avez créé votre opportunités d'après ce
que je vois exactement
mehdi transport mais difficultés ont
l'opportunité c'est parfait mais dites
moi en tant que femmes immigrantes
est ce que c'est un atout c'est un
c'est un autre défi et en tant que femme
imminente
ça dépend est ce que c'est une femme
immigrante célibataires familles dante
femme de mère de famille si à l'époque
j'avais des enfants
je dirais que ça aurait été plus
difficile donc je parle de mon
expérience à l'époque
disons que c'était plus facile pour moi
de tenter plusieurs choses c'est quand
on arrive en famille on est limité en
imiter dans une région on vient il ya
louis dia le bayer l'école des enfants
aussi qu'ils posent les enfants qui nous
lie mais péter comme on est obligé de
travailler dans les alentours pour pas
s'éloigner en tant que femme marocaine
ou arabes en général immigrants j'ai en
fait pour chaque réussite il faut faire
l'effort
si on fait pas l'effort il n'y a pas de
résultats donc moi j'ai fait les ports a
vraiment jeu
je me suis battu corps et âme de 10 ans
mais parce que j'avais une stratégie
dont il faut avoir une vision qu'il faut
pas avoir déjà la barre très haute dès
le début il faut commencer quelque part
puis définir la démarche des étapes se
dire ok moi ma vision dans dix ans être
la directrice générale mais au début
tiens on se dit oh ça se peut pas on est
dans un pays où c'est plus les québécois
c'est plus masculin ce plus mais vous
savez quoi dans mon équipe
on n'est plus des femmes que des hommes
c'est pas par choix par compétences et
et j'ai dans mon équipe j'ai des
tunisiens j'ai mexicains 1 vénézuélien
j'ai français suisses en plus de
québécois paie quand j'étais venu au
cégep à l'institut et à l'époque il n'y
avait pas cette mentalité d'accueillir
des immigrants ont présent trouvé avec
vous j'ai su que vous aviez deux filles
donc vous par rapport aux défis que vous
avez lu pensez vous que ces défis seront
les mains pour vos filles et où c'est
vraiment c'est une toute autre réalité
je dirais que avec méfier puis
l'intégration plus facile parce que
toute façon dans l'eure au cpe parce que
j'ai deux fils de très jeunes âgés de 4
et 6 ans affecté au cpi il était 100%
intégrée avec des québécois c'est pas
par choix mais c'est le cpu il ya c'est
la vérité de la réalité ensuite
maintenant à l'école ils sont vraiment
bien intégrés et parle de culture
québécoise ça fait partie de leur adn
maintenant maintenant le défi c'est le
contraire c'est comment comment amener
le marocaines ont leur quartier que
marie la culture la culture religieuse
la culture c'est l'intégration
al'inverse mai mais les défis pour pour
mes enfants en particulier
par expérience je trouve que ce seras ce
sera plus facile pour accéder à l'emploi
c'est plus facile de de progresser et
d'évoluer parce que aussi ici la culture
qu'on a appris que ça faisait pas passer
de notre apprentissage nous au maroc
mais c'est une culture ouverte que la
discussion la communication avec les
enfants c'est un peu différent de ce
qu'on a vécu comment ont été éduqués qui
a plus de partage ma fille ella 6 ans
elle partageait parle de politique elle
a suivi les élections de jordan c'est
parce que l'environnement le permet à
l'école ils leur disent est ce que vous
avez voté t es ce que vous avez fait
votre devoir citoyen ça fait partie
alors que nous tiens je me rappel le
maroc les élections étrangers rendus
adultes là que j'ai su qu'il y avait des
élections que je pouvais aller mais j'ai
jamais suivi à la lettre
c'est une autre réalité certaine exact
alors dit moi je vous pose une question
très classique mais à bien la pause et
c'est quoi votre définition de la
réussite vous comment vous êtes un
modèle de réussite pour les ports défi
pour les hommes aussi
quelle est votre définition de la
réussite
j'irai que la plupart du monde qui lie
la réussite à tout ce qui est un gain
monétaire à tout ce qui est un poste à
haut niveau ou à tout ce qui est
popularité pour moi c'est simple c'est
la réussite c'est être heureux être
vraiment un accomplissement de soi peu
importe ce qu'on fait dans la vie si on
est heureux dans l'accomplissement de
nos activités dans l'exercice de nos
fonctions si on est heureux à sortir le
matin pour aller travailler et et qu'on
fait c'est un équilibre aussi entre le
travail et la vie familiale la vie la
vie en général la vie sociale qui cet
équilibre qui est important c'est pas
vraiment atteindre des niveaux
je veux être je peux faire n'importe
quel métier et puis réussir c'est ça la
réussite pour moi c'est pas vraiment
être l'adjectif général touché un
salaire de x de l'armée mais vraiment je
viens chaque matin il doit on n'a pas de
bien encore au bureau parce que les
services essentiels
donc chaque matin je viens au bureau je
suis motivé je me donne à fond je
travaille même la nuit
mais parce que c'est j'aime ce que je
fais tes on se donne à fond parce qu'on
aime
puis on veut être une valeur ajoutée
pour comme j'ai dit le pays qui nous a
accueillis mais même pour soi c'est un
accomplissement de soi autant pas les
diplômes qu'on a réalisé mais on
arrêtait avoir des diplômes c'est pas ça
la réussite oui on a réussi mais c'est
une partie cédé à perte dans la vie on
fixe des objectifs qui ça commence par
ces du king ça commence par apprendre
et puis il faut pas oublier que il faut
avoir l'esprit ouvert et il faut
accueillir les cultures des autres il
faut accueillir les critiques il faut
qu'il faut agir même les défaites
parce que c'est grâce à ces défaites
qu'on progresse
c'est sûr qu'on va on va se blesser mais
on va analyser on veut dire ok on va se
mettre debout plus fort que quand on
était ce qui ne me tue pas me rend fort
finale
exactement c'est la personnalité se voir
sur ces forges
puis la réussite via à travers toutes
ses multiples réalisations multiples
objectifs atteints et c'est là qu'on
récolte par la suite les fruits de notre
nos enfants merci beaucoup navale rallye
je rappelle que vous êtes est la
directrice de l'institut d'innovation en
logistique du québec merci beaucoup
merci merci beaucoup merci pour
l'invitation